the following is rated s for spoilers
from the network that brought you
Breaking Bad assure you couldn't stop
watching comes a show so inconsistent
you have to keep talking yourself into
watching The Walking Dead enter the
aftermath of a zombie apocalypse where
no one says the word zombie walkers lamb
brains lurkers geeks corpses dead but
spiders walk walk walk walk walk what do
you call mob where humanity goes back to
riding horses fighting with crossbows
and driving the fully loaded 2012
Hyundai Tucson damn they keep that thing
clean saddle up with the group the group
seems supportive
this group is brokerage I'm keeping this
group together featuring Rick the leader
who stands by his decisions until he
doesn't I won't leave again I have to go
your place is here this isn't a
democracy we vote we don't kill the
living meet his best friend Shay who
left him for dead slept with his wife
and tried to kill him twice you know
typical best breadstuff Darrow the
sexiest redneck in Georgia Glenn who
used the apocalypse to date way out of
his League Oh
[Music]
the last person you want to be stuck in
an apocalypse with all these people who
were just kind of there and Laurie the
most hated character on a show full of
fleshy monsters
watch as he pawned off her kid crashes
our corn and Abbey Road and even in
death is literally haunting the show
with her annoying presence I can't help
she's the worst together they'll travel
with the cast of supporting characters
like tdawg okay then Merle Andrea Dale
zombie Shane Sophia Amy those Prison
dudes
anyone what
man the actors on Game of Thrones a
better job security but the undead
aren't the only thing after the group
they'll also have to keep an eye out for
the governor the nicest mass murderer
since lots of huggin bear have a look
around who knows I like what you see why
Jesse ruthlessly guns down innocent
people including his own constituents
because he's crazy yeah definitely crazy
fans of the comic have been waiting
years to see their favorite characters
come to life on the small screen and
after three seasons they're still
waiting instead witnesses season about
the group's desperate search for answers
and uneven season about a fight for
survival and season two man dead farm
starring filthy clothing infinite ammo
basic-cable nudity improbable headshots
group debate let's just see where
everybody stands and we can talk to the
options dale face ugly cry face
Briggs hat
gun safety and make sure you got a round
in the chamber and you safety off take
the safety off and now the safety works
by jacks all right
watch where you beat did you get bit
zombie extras drinking water stuff until
I stop stuff things silent hand gestures
and Shane rubbing his head
the walking dead man I can't wait for
the first half of season 4 to be super
awesome and the second had to be super
lame thanks for watching be sure to
subscribe I'm gonna punch you in the
butt crack apology accepted captain
needa I like turtles
machete don't text I am the one who
knocks